before we go here is one thing you can  do today to live a happier healthier and  more productive life it's thanks to our  partnership with Gretchen Rubin and her  award-winning podcast happier  researchers found 20% of people are  chronic procrastinators and most of us  delay even simple tasks the 1-minute  rule is an easy tool if you get  overwhelmed it goes like this  but TAS takes less than one minute  complete it right away even the busiest  person can follow this rule  research shows being consistent will  help new habits become a part of your  routine it's good advice like sometimes  we avoid even the simple things you're  good timer for that yeah we've got 10  seconds oh not a minute does it for us  we'll see you tomorrow on CBS this  morning